what's happening there reject nation we
got the mics on so that way we can hear
each other laugh loudly clearly for
brooklyn nine-nine
um yeah leave a like if you can that'd
be very much appreciated i would say if
you can i know you can well if you don't
have fingers how are you accessing this
video subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction from the next benign is up
also uh full-length watch along so we
sync up with the time code available for
our super sexy rejects the right rejects
over at our patreon page thanks to all
who have followed us so far and lastly
them pepper boys next to help us edit
this down what episode is this this is
episode 12 of season 3 let's get to it
who are you wearing porridge
oatmeal
oh my god he didn't even wipe it off
he's totally given up on life it's
loneliness ever since kevin left for a
sabbatical in paris he hasn't been the
same [ __ ] kevin that's lonely
oh this is how you do it a case flow
yeah yeah gloves work i thought all your
cases were closed you were bragging
about it so much last night i couldn't
hear the end of the neighbor's fight it
ended in sex it always does it didn't
make me horny it's
oh
i'm going to make him forget about his
sadness through the power of
distraction
he's gone
oh andrew seemed like he was channeling
his jim carrey there hola mi capitan why
am i speaking italian you might ask that
was spanish yeah
but they're similar joey garibaldi was a
mafia lieutenant about eight years ago i
was closing in on him when he
disappeared i'm hearing chatter on the
street that he's back in town will you
help me come in yes thank you very much
sir uh good bye y'all
i have a great trick fill in all the
bubbles with whiteout jams the machine
everyone passes these are practice for
the lieutenant's exam they're kicking my
butt i can't get better than 70
c minus the perfect grade you pass but
you're still
hot look at me i've had no official
dance training yet here i stand
a miracle of movement
you do you gina jason died this morning
sorry it's terrible
it's your front of yours he was my dog
oh okay so no big deal
oh he was going to town one of my snow
boots and his little heart just gave out
he didn't even finish gross oh
he's in every photograph
nick ditullio i actually brought him in
eight years ago but he refused to talk
of course you know the saying
time shall open up the mouth of every
man to the truth of his neighbor all
right it's a real saint
it's not like we were close i was just
his trainer at the gym then why were you
always going out to dinner with him was
he doing reps of linguine noice
emergency at the gym just when two cops
show up at his door that seems
suspicious we should follow him yeah
every day on this job
is a wonder
damn right it is
medical examiner jackpot the gym is full
of bodies no
there's been an outbreak of the mumps
mumps that's a funny word it's actually
a very serious and highly contagious
infectious disease i'm afraid you both
have the mumps oh no
oh
are we gonna die
are you vaccinated you may not want to
be her detective oh it's cool i keep up
to date on all my vaccinations i'm
immune to stuff you've never even heard
of but not immune to braggadocio
not immune to that sick burn you will
both be quarantined to your houses for
the next nine days we could be
quarantined together you know work the
case it's gonna be the best week ever
i'm sorry did you not hear me say
extreme testicular discomfort yes we
heard you dr bad news doctor oscar from
office
so for the next two weeks captain holt
will be on medical leave which means i
am the acting captain and we are your
royal subjects to continue
complete these 22 additional tasks every
time we check one off the list you're
gonna hear this bell
it's the sound of victory
[Laughter]
you steal that from a cold stone i'd
like to introduce you to someone
oh his name is simon oh boy and i hate
him hello simon
this is balthazar
spin-off i kind of want to poke my mump
bad idea i'm going in here we go oh
it hurt
how did i not see that coming that was
gross
i get my butt back to work good you go
through all the witness statements yet
by work i meant on jason's in memoriam
video take a look what i got so far
oh
how weird are forks forks are very weird
i've always thought so yeah did we take
too much cold medicine not by a long
shot balthazar is a thirsty
[Laughter]
it on [ __ ]
that's right nine-nine that's the sound
of the victory belt we just crossed our
first task off the list terry that is so
great which one was it fixed belt
oh god no one eats the sub get back to
work
oh no rebellion mutiny he slipped the
chef a piece of paper i bet it's the
address of his hideout the chef knows
where the hideout is go where are you oh
what's on your face huh oh right uh yes
my disgusting deformity um
here let me just
ooh
we're on our way right now to talk to
our dude
you're quarantined you can't go outside
spewing mumps like a couple of mum
fountains not like this we can't
yes
this is aged well
good luck trying to stop us
you'll never catch us
is this the piece of paper you're
looking for you found the address
[Laughter]
your wall the entire time you're
delirious and you're sick and you
definitely didn't solve the case you
need to go back inside well i can't
i like stopped working no
we just have to buckle down and work
harder we simply hit a bump in the road
more like a mump
in the road
[Laughter]
the plan is working perfectly hold
hasn't been lonely all week yeah because
he's too busy almost dying look at him
what he's just beautiful minding it
jake
enough is enough you need to drop this
stupid back burner cold case before you
both die
oh my god i thought i was following her
[Laughter]
what are you doing just sealing jason's
collar in airtight bag so it retains his
scent look i know that dog meant a lot
to you so i got you this
oh
i can't just replace jason with some
other dog why not all dogs are basically
the same go hunt that toy
that's jason's
look man
what are you cute doggy his humping was
the only thing that got me through my
divorce seeing him so happy made me
believe that i could be happy one day
too
you wouldn't understand this because you
have a motorcycle helmet for a heart
i'm gonna use that at some point what's
going on with those files oh we're not
working on them we're on strike hunger
strike and i'll do everyone's work
because apparently i am the only one
keeping this precinct together
oh my god
mothazar has a sister meet
penelope oh god
we should get back to work or we could
fall asleep for five to seven days and
see how we feel i will not rest till
justice is served
the case may not be quite as urgent as
once thought
i dug it up out of my desk so you'd have
something to do on weekends because you
seem so lonely so you lied to me had a
pity you pitied me i wouldn't put it
that way i would i am offended i am
angry oh so i'm gonna take a nap but
when i wake up ugh
you are in for it
how dare you
[Laughter]
do that
you said we were out of peas you pee
gotta people
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay hope you guys are hungry made fake
ziti
thought it would be fun to use
garibaldi's ultra authentic recipe
pity food
thank you anyway but i can cook for
myself wow i would roll my eyes so hard
right now if it didn't make my brain
burn okay captain
but no one ever took pity on you all we
wanted to do was help you when you were
down because that's what people do when
they care about each other they tell
each other lies and invent urgent
mysteries that need to be solved
back to you amy we're doing great you're
gonna eat the ziti and you're gonna
appreciate it and you're gonna grow the
hell up you're right
i'm sorry for the way i acted and the
zd's gonna help solve the case
oh
this is revolting
oh god
that is worse than the mums amy
i used garibaldi's exact recipe i know
i'm not a great cook but i love
following instructions okay seven cups
of salt even i know this isn't a recipe
which means it might be a coat
718 brooklyn area code yes that's
definitely it
wait did you actually use all of this
salt and 18 cups of oregano back off i
solved the case nine onions
amy how am i the bad guy here
[Laughter]
the only difference between you and holt
is that he lacks the strength to close a
door so hard a room blows up
thanks gina ah you don't have to thank
me all i did was be the only person who
believes in you don't lean against the
door terry caused structural damage oh
my god you're strong dude that panther
blouse though
what is this it's a funeral for jason
i'm gonna say a few words
jason died seven days ago i didn't give
a rat's ass
i've only had arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill everyone in this room
[Laughter]
i was too proud to admit i was lonely
thank you you're welcome and an even
bigger thing is that you brought me back
to the nine-nine and i'll always be
grateful for that so oh here
this is for you
i missed you so much
thank you for this gift
[Music]
thank you for this gift ah [ __ ] cast and
crew of brooklyn nine nine
that was sweet
i would hate to be quarantined with you
i yeah i mean you know it probably would
get uh pretty tense up in there we would
be
uh could barely handle several hours in
here together
yeah a nightmare mm-hmm
although you know so i was thinking the
whole time who knows though like i like
this show but i'd hate to be experience
this with john and it's ruining my
relationship with him actively as we sit
here
forcing me to contemplate it live it out
in my mind and realize how much i would
hate it going to mistreat him now
based off of something that hasn't
happened at all based off a what if fan
example of how i imagined the most
negative quarantine situation would go
between us it's okay that's the perfect
start because then eventually
we would get so delirious that we end up
having fun again and doing stuff off the
clock that we used to do before you know
we were always in this room together
yeah and then you know we would learn a
valuable lesson about friendship but
then in a twist of fate you know we'd
forget it because we were delirious and
then by the time we're better you know
we'll just get back to work yeah yeah
we only have fun when the camera is
wrong
we have very planned out fun
mathematically mapped out like we got no
don't do do don't start laughing now we
gotta wait for the camera laughter for
when the camera's rolling
a joke and the camera is not on what
that would
have made a subscriber laugh
that could have equals a subscription we
can't replicate that in the moment
someone might have hit the like for that
joke yeah
um that was a sweet episode it was i
actually really liked the lesson that
terry learned i know
something has
been stuck with me for a few couple
months now forget when i heard it
i was at the gym
contemplating working out
standing over here
[Laughter]
are these games really worth can i just
sit in the sauna for like 20 minutes
what about leg day tomorrow
um i was
i was uh i was listening to this audio
and it was talking about um it's tony
robbins i'll just say it i feel like
it's kind of weird to me when you listen
to tony robbins
this is tony robbins audio
and
uh he was talking about essentially how
a lot of times when we're growing in
life or growing in work or business
whatever that it feels like
uh you're trying to reach this point
where you don't have any problems but
that's such an unrealistic goal is that
the the thing to embrace is that you
have to be a problem solver and
you're going to that's what
equates growth that's what allows you to
earn and that's what allows you to reap
more is knowing that you're going to
always have problems and that it's about
solving them
and
um
yeah so this whole thing about
you know what terry was going through
kind of reminding me of that and that
it's like now when you're up there when
you're higher up in a leadership
position it's about putting out fires
so
uh yeah i just thought that was a nice
little personal reminder
and that's why we're never going to
quarantine together john it's too many
problems you can't put out you gotta
know your limits too
that's true it's true don't blow up the
office when you close the door and go
out
well whenever we gotta get uh covet
tests for this premiere we gotta go to
yeah and i'm always nervous about it
every time i get a coveted like what if
it's what if it's positive i've avoided
for years saying no
what if now it's the time i get it i
calculate every group activity i do with
utmost precision in order to maximize
those risks so that i don't end up with
a surprise cove and positive i get
tested at least once a month and and now
i have never caught it and now i'm like
what if now's the time what if what if i
caught it at one point and i just didn't
know
you know that's the ultimate thing
that's the ultimate thing but that's the
best thing then because if you got to
this point and yeah i didn't feel like
you caught it
around you caught it you know like you
didn't have it i'll leave it and have
thank you vaccine um yeah i i i like
this um
i like this mumps episode
good makeup disturbing makeup disturbing
but yeah quality well i think the comedy
with them is great because uh andy
sandberg's response to that because you
know it's like
actors when they put on you know makeup
and stuff it makes them feel a certain
different way you know you kind of lean
into the prosthetics
and
i like seeing how both of these guys
reacted differently to
wearing wearing the prosthetics and then
giving into the sickness and i liked
seeing how their performances change
based off of that yeah but also how they
complement each other so well they just
they just really
ebb and flow really well together
yeah i know they're they have i think
yeah this this ensemble has certain duos
that work really well and holt and andy
or holt and jake is absolutely
one of them because you get two you get
two for one with them it's like when
they're clicking that's its own dynamic
that's really fun to watch them play off
each other and top each other but you
know be
kind of in harmony as well and then when
they come back to being sort of yeah
that that friction of the authority
versus you know the subordinate
uh yeah like they're just such great
comedic actors and again like andre
brower especially like really makes
those moments sing
and yeah like this episode it was great
because because
you know is another one of those where
each of the three plot lines like even
the jason plotline which is probably
like you know my
the the the i put it at the bottom of my
favorite totem
the dog yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but even that was like
sweet and the whole thing was rosa so
yeah yeah no absolutely like i'm saying
like i i wouldn't
i'm not trying to slide it by saying
it's my third favorite plot but but you
know in one of those episodes where by
the end you know i was like oh wow all
three of these were really sweet and
charming in their own way and they also
had you know some really great absurd
heights
uh and so yeah like this was one that
really represented i think like the
heart and the charm of the ensemble and
yeah when they come up with some kind of
trio of stories that are not exactly the
same or exactly about the same you know
theme but they all feel like they sort
of harmonize together like yeah but like
like you said look like with the terry
story i really enjoyed
just like the episodic nature of that
but by the end it was like oh wow like i
really appreciate what this amounted to
and i didn't necessarily see that coming
so much
and uh and even amy like amy is kind of
the rogue for this episode because she's
sort of floating around in the middle
but like i loved also just her moments
of being like
really authoritative yeah uh and and not
leaning in very much to her nebushy side
so like you know i thought it gave
everybody something interesting
yeah very true yeah i mean it's a good
one good one because the episode well
thank you guys for being here i don't
see this show ever faltering and
wavering down in any season whatsoever
possible possible never happens in
long-running comedy sitcoms
comedy sitcoms comedy sitcoms comedy
situation comedy unlike those dramas
yeah yeah this this comedy sitcom only
takes place in wacky circumstances
banana peels are everywhere it's all
clown [ __ ]
um
guys leave your thoughts down below
appreciate you being here and hey let's
do a page
daniel gallacher
ah screw it we're gonna do it you'll be
a great person to be quarantined with i
don't know why because you're the
pharmacist guys
medical stuff we know how to do this
symptoms and all that stuff get our
goiters down you'd be perfect for that
freeze our testicles three years of you
being here and that's bringing up the
pharmaceutical background
lidocaine we can't come up with anything
else
does that work maybe it's psychological
the blood is naming the blood
medications
i don't really know what you stopped
you're from sounds like
is
all of our vitamins and medicines
minerals
we love you
[Music]